oh
bonjour merci de nous rejoindre en
direct du sénat pour la séance des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
que vous allez pouvoir suivre en direct
sur notre antenne dans quinze petites
minutes à partir de 15h mais auparavant
nous recevons sur le plateau de public
sénat marisol touraine
la ministre des affaires sociales et de
la santé bonjour merci d'être avec nous
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale a été rejetée ce matin
par le sénat alors comment la suite de
l'histoire va s'écrire maintenant le
texte va retourner à l'assemblée
nationale il va suivre son chemin et
donc sur le plan juridique sur le plan
politique il y aura bien sûr dans
quelques semaines un budget de la
sécurité sociale qui marquera des
avancées significatives en matière de
droits sociaux de protection en
direction des français ce matin le sénat
a fait le choix de rejeter la partie
recettes c'est-à-dire les ressources
nouvelles qui vont aller dans la
sécurité sociale sans même aborder les
enjeux de dépenses c'est à dire la
manière dont on conçoit l'assurance
maladie la santé pour nos concitoyens et
je le regrette je le dis puisque que
l'opposition se soit opposé c'est
classique est attendue
ou que le voilà le haut selon me nice
n'a pas souhaité voter ce texte moi je
regrette je l' ai déjà dit que la
majorité n'est pas été rassemblées et je
le répète n'est pas été rassemblés pour
un texte qui apporte de nouvelles
protections et de nouveaux droits aux
français mais parce que les sénateurs du
front de gauche trouve que les mesures
de justice sociale dans le texte sont
insuffisantes
eliane assassi la présidente du groupe
accusent même le gouvernement d'être
dans la rigueur
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez il y a
la volonté de faire preuve de
responsabilité et moi je le dis très
simplement et très clairement ça n'est
pas en creusant le déficit de la
sécurité sociale que nous apporterons
des garanties solides aux français dans
la durée vous savez si le déficit de la
sécurité sociale continue alors
pourront pas faire face à nos
obligations et ce sont les assurances
privées qui seront les grandes gagnantes
mais en réalité je crois qu'il y a dans
le même temps le refus de voir certaines
avancées très forte qu'il y a dans ce
texte en faveur de l'hôpital public en
faveur des retraités par exemple des
retraités des secteurs de l'amiante en
faveur d'une médecine de proximité qui
apporte davantage de garanties aux
français donc il y à toute une série de
mesures qui n'ont même pas été évoqué et
je le regrette
donc vous dites aujourd'hui tant pis
pour le sénat tant pis pour les taxes
aussi qu'ils ont été adoptés par la
haute assemblée
cette semaine on pense notamment à
l'amendement qu'on appelle l'amendement
nutella
que va-t-il devenir je ne sais pas
encore je ne sais pas si des députés
souhaiteront reprendre l or au moment de
cet amendement qui était d'un amendement
d'origine parlementaire sénatoriales je
dois dire que pour ma part je suis très
réservé sur la multiplication de taxes
sur les produits alimentaires car je
crois que nous avions besoin c'est ce
que c'est ce qui va se passer par
devront en séance ici c'est ce qui est
c'est ce qui a été retenu et on tombe
sur l'aspartame la taxe l'admets mais il
faut une politique de santé publique
le gouvernement l'a dit il y aura une
loi de santé publique en 2013 et c'est à
cette occasion qu'il nous faudra marquer
des orientations des priorités et des
moyens d'action comment mieux prévenir
comment mieux garantir la santé des
français
donc moi je suis réservé sur des
politiques qui au fond se contentent de
taxer sans que soit fait le lien
clairement avec des enjeux de santé
publique mais nous verrons comment les
députés choisissent de s'emparer de
cette question mais en tout cas
en tout état de cause vous restez vous
sur votre position défendue ici au sénat
oui bien sûr quelles que soient les
amendements l'assemblée nationale oui
bien sûr mais le débat se poursuit en
même temps le texte que nous avons
présentés à l'origine a été enrichi il a
été transformé par les débats
parlementaires
à l'évidence les députés vont souhaitait
conforter la position où les positions
qu'ils ont portés lors des discussions
précédentes et je crois que c'est
dommage aussi pour
les sénateurs que leur contribution ne
puisse pas être mieux entendus et mieux
retenu ce qui se passe ici au sénat à
l'intérieur de la majorité est ce que
c'est révélateur de l'inquiétude de
toute l'ailé gauche du parti socialiste
et puis de vos partenaires aussi de
l'extrême gauche vis-à-vis du nouveau
cap économiques fixés par le chef de
l'état le parti socialiste et rassembler
et il y a un cap qui a été fixé par le
président de la république écrit alliés
celui qui est celui sur lequel il a fait
campagne et je veux le dire clairement
le président de la firme harris sociale
libérale de ces deux dernières semaines
n'étaient pas aussi net pendant la
campagne comme président de la
république a été élu sur un projet de
vérité il n'a pas caché les efforts
qu'il y aurait à réaliser il a indiqué
qu'il voulait inscrire sa politique dans
la perspective du rétablissement des
comptes publics
et en même temps faire en sorte que ce
rétablissement financier se fasse dans
le respect de règles de justice et les
règles de justice et celle que l'on
trouve par exemple dans ce texte sur la
sécurité sociale donc c'est bien là le
paradoxe il faut à la fois une politique
de responsabilité financière et en même
temps apporter des réponses des réponses
en matière de retraite c'est ce que nous
avons fait dès notre arrivée aux
responsabilités en matière de soutien
aux familles c'est ce que nous avons
fait avec l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire en matière de santé c'est ce
que nous faisons en ce moment avec
l'accord sur les dépassements
d'honoraires ou avec le renforcement de
la proximité où les droits des femmes et
donc je le dis là là il n'y a pas une
tournant dans la politique
gouvernementale et je crois que les
français en votant pour françois
hollande ont voté pour des choix de
responsabilité de justice tout à la fois
mais comment vous expliquer alors qu'on
entend des inquiétudes à l'agoa gauche
et qu'en revanche laurence parisot
françois bâillon aussi applaudissent les
mesures annoncées par françois hollande
l'ump n'a pas voté pour le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
ici aujourd'hui au sénat mais le medef
certaine mesure
énoncé le medef approuve des mesures
l'engagement en faveur du pacte de
compétitivité
comment imaginer que l'on puisse se
désintéressait de la compétitivité de
nos entreprises et de la compétitivité
de notre économie
l'enjeu il n'est pas celui là il est de
faire en sorte que cette compétitivité
ne soit pas reconquise au détriment des
consommateurs au détriment des ménages
des français nous avons un effort
considérable a réalisé chacun doit y
contribuer mais à l'évidence il
n'appartient pas aux français les plus
modestes de faire les efforts principaux
pour parler justement des médecins vous
avez évoqué cette question il y a un
instant marisol touraine
vous avez déclaré dimanche que le
gouvernement ne reviendra pas sur la
liberté d'installation des médecins
alors comment vous comptez lutter contre
les déserts médicaux la liberté
d'installation est un principe auquel
les médecins mais aussi je crois les
français sont attachés et donc je veux
dissiper les inquiétudes ou les
malentendus il n'y aura pas pour les
jeunes médecins de contraintes à
l'installation nous savons que les
déserts médicaux contre les déserts
médicaux ont grandi que nous disent les
jeunes médecins ils nous disent nous ne
voulons plus travailler dans les mêmes
conditions que les générations qui nous
ont précédés nous voulons du travail en
équipe nous voulons de la simplification
administrative nous voulons des
relations avec des hôpitaux de proximité
et ça cela que nous faisons maison
médicale ça existe déjà dans les lieux
d'un volatile un peu mais les médecins
que je rencontre les jeunes me disent ne
savons pas où aller lorsque nous sortons
de nos études et que nous disons nous
voulons aller nous installer dans une
zone rurale nous ne savons pas où donc
nous mettons en place y compris dans le
projet de loi qui est actuellement en
discussions maintenant qui repart à
l'assemblée nous mettons en place des
médecins territoriaux en médecine
générale qui vont pouvoir être
accompagné au cours des deux premières
années de leur installation
nous renforçons les relations avec les
hôpitaux de proximité nous
rémunérons le travail en équipe et nous
allons procéder à des simplifications
administratives j'aurai l'occasion dans
les prochaines semaines d'annoncer un
plan global d'ensemble parce qu'il n'ya
pas une mesure magique
il n'y a pas la mesure qui permet de les
déserts des deux buts et il faut avoir
une grande volonté d'aboutir ce qui n'a
pas été le cas jusqu'à maintenant en
quelques sortes il faut sonner la
mobilisation générale
et c'est ce que le gouvernement va faire
vous avez souligné tout à l'heure
l'accord qui a été conclu avec les
médecins sur les dépassements
d'honoraires comment vous expliquez
pourtant que cet accord soit critiquée
par plusieurs syndicats de médecins les
la majorité des syndicats représentatifs
de médecins libéraux a signé cet accord
qui permet de sanctionner les tarifs
abusifs de mieux rembourser les français
lorsque leurs médecins pratiquent des
tarifs raisonnables et de garantir aux
français modem qui apportent aux
français modestes des garanties de
tarifs remboursés par la sécurité
sociale
certains médecins qui ne sont pas
signataires n'acceptent pas le principe
même de l'encadrement il va l'aider
quasiment donnant derniers étaient peu
nombreux dans la rue il ya des jeunes et
des médecins qui refusent cela moi je
veux dire clairement qu'il faut faire
une différence entre ce qui au fond
veulent défendre la liberté de tarifs
complète et puis d'autres médecins qui
ont le sentiment que leur métier est en
plein bouleversement et qui parfois se
sente mise en cause ou mal aimé
nous avons besoin des médecins la très
grande majorité des médecins travaillent
de façon tout à fait raisonnable et est
hautement respectable il n'y a pas de
remise en cause de notre part de la
pratique de l'ensemble des médecins il
ya la volonté que la produire des règles
du jeu est-ce qu il se doit les exonérer
de tout effort vis-à-vis de la
collectivité en période de clans
justement mais pas simplement en période
de crise mais particulièrement aux
périodes de crise
le fait que nous demandions que les
règles du jeu soient plus claires que
ces règles du jeu soient celles de la
justice ne veut pas dire que nous
remettons en cause le travail des
médecins ou que l'on stigmatise ion que
nous montrons du doigt les médecins les
médecins évidemment nous en avons besoin
leur métier est en plein changement et
je crois qu'il ya des évolutions dans la
société
certains d'entre eux vivent mal ces
évolutions ou le sentiment qu'à travers
la transformation de leur métier qu'à
travers la transformation des attentes
des français et bien c'est une partie de
leur avenir qui est en jeu
moi je suis prête à construire le
système de santé de l'avenir avec eux
mais il faut bien qu'on peut avoir
apaisé les esprits et il faut bien
comprendre que il faut qu'il y ait les
règles et que les français ont le droit
de savoir qu'ils pourront se soigner
demain sans obstacles financiers sans
obstacles géographiques
dernière question marisol touraine ya
des négociations paritaires qui ont
repris aujourd'hui autour de la
sécurisation du parcours professionnel
le patronat a mis ses conditions sur la
table aujourd'hui l'assouplissement du
cdi
la facilitation aussi des plans sociaux
est ce que ces revendications du
patronat vous semble légitime août et
nous sommes au début de la négociation
chacun vient avec ses demandes présente
ses objectifs et il me paraît nécessaire
que ces objectifs soient clairement
identifiés pour que la discussion puisse
avoir lieu
un accord sera un bon accord si il
permet à la fois de faciliter le travail
des entreprises de renforcer leur
compétitivité et dans le même temps de
d'apporter de nouvelles sécurités aux
salariés c'est dans ce que le président
de la république a appelé un compromis
historique que nous verrons aussi au
fond il sera là tories nous sommes au
début du processus aux négociateurs et
aux partenaires sociaux de saisir
l'importance du moment pour notre
économie mais aussi pour les droits des
salariés semble partir sur de bonnes
bases en tout cas écoutez il y a une
volonté
de discuter et une volonté d'avancer de
part et d'autre je crois maintenant il y
aura des différences nous verrons
comment ce temps de négociation permet
d'avancer très bien mes côtés je vous
remercie beaucoup marisol touraine
devenu sur notre plateau à 600 séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je vais vous laisser rejoindre
l'hémicycle du sénat puisque la séance
va débuter dans une minute ou deux
séance des questions d'actualité
aujourd'hui consacrés notamment avec
plusieurs questions au pacte de
compétitivité annoncé la semaine
dernière par le gouvernement
des questions sur ce point à la fois de
l'ump des centristes par la voix de leur
président françois zocchetto mais
également des socialistes et puis le
gouvernement va également être
interpellé cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle sur la question des gaz de
schiste c'est yvon collin le sénateur
radical qui va poser cette question à
laquelle répondra delphine batho la
ministre de l'ecologie vauquelin qui est
plutôt favorable à l'exploitation des
gaz de schiste il viendra après sur
notre plateau ici en salle des
conférences pour se confronter avec
hélène ni pièces une sénatrice verte qui
elle vint interpellé le gouvernement sur
l'arrestation d'aurore martin vous savez
cette militante basque
beaucoup d'élus du sud ouest de la
france notamment des élus communistes
mais aussi des élus verts se sont
engagés aux côtés de rohr martin on
verra ce qu'en dira sur ce plateau après
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
alain vidalis le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement
donc vous avez compris on va suivre dans
quelques instants et j'entends la
sonnerie de la séance qui retentit eh
bien on va suivre en direct la séance
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement au sénat
et puis après sur ce plateau situé dans
la salle des conférences qui est juste à
côté de l'hémicycle du sénat et bien
viendront débattre après la séance des
sénateurs des ministres sur les
différents points d'actualité abordés
ici au sénat cet après midi voilà la
porte du cabinet de départ c'est-à-dire
les cabinets où se retrouvent à la fois
le président du sénat est le premier
ministre ou le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement
s'est ouverte on voit on les voit se
diriger tranquillement mais sûrement
vers l'hémicycle du sénat ce qui
signifie que d'ici une minute cette
séance pourra démarrer je vous rappelle
que dix questions sont posées au
gouvernement
les différents groupes politiques du
sénat ont chacun un temps bien défini
pour interpeller tous les quinze jours
le gouvernement les ministres sur les
questions d'actualité
qu'ils choisissent eux mêmes voilà est
une grande liberté de choix dans
l'actualité sur ces questions on va
attendre que jean pierre bel le
président du sénat s'installe à la
tribune de l'hémicycle pour que la
séance puisse démarrer et voilà c'est
parti on se retrouve dans une heure
la séance est reprise
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle peut-être avec un peu
d'insistance cet après midi que l'auteur
de la question
ministre ou sénateurs disposent de deux
minutes trente
je vous demande d'être attentifs à ce
délai pour la première question la
parole et à madame marie hélène des
esgaulx pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre
après toutes les péripéties de votre
communication
il y aura donc un avant et un après
rapport gallois avant ce rapport de
louis gallois qui constitue du reste un
diagnostic intéressant votre
gouvernement à commencer par supprimer
la tva compétitivité institué par
nicolas sarkozy votée par la précédente
majorité et vous aviez comme le candidat
président françois hollande promis de ne
pas augmenter la tva
six mois plus tard dès le lendemain de
la remise officielle de ce rapport
gallois vous faites linverse
reconnaissant implicitement que vous
avez fait des choix erroné selon un
calendrier il adapté
en tout état de cause nous avons perdu
six mois je voudrais vous interpeller
car la conséquence de tout cela c'est
que personne ne peut plus voter en
l'état je dis bien en l'état le budget
2013 que vous présentait il ya ceux qui
croient aux rapports gallois qui
constate que le budget 2013 ne tiennent
pas compte des préconisations du rapport
est que elles ne seront intégrés
budgétairement quand 2014
franchement mes chers collègues comme si
on pouvait se permettre d'attendre 2014
et puis il ya ceux qui sont contre ce
rapport dans votre propre majorité et
qui ne peuvent enregistrer
je le dis sincèrement que des reculs que
dès que des renoncements par rapport à
des promesses de campagne alors je
repose la question
qui peut voter en l'état ce budget 2013
moi je vous rappelle qu'un budget c'est
l'instrument financier une politique car
vous dîtes nous ce n'est peut-être pas
suffisant il faudra il doit être en tout
état de cause ce budget il doit être un
instrument financier d'une politique il
faut qu'il soit d'abord un moment de
vérité et en l'état actuel ce document
budgétaire
il est dépassé il ne correspond plus à
l' inflexion de la politique que vous
avez décidé de suivre
suite au rapport aux gallois c'est
vraiment dommage parce que je pense que
notre pays mérite mieux
alors je me le dis avec une certaine
gravité à défaut de le dire au premier
ministre qu'il n'est pas là je le dis à
vous mesdames et messieurs les ministres
qui avaient chacun en responsabilité une
partie du budget 2013 est bien la vérité
céder ce budget 2013
la vérité c'est maintenant merci pour
vous répondre monsieur pierre moscovici
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice ds go je veux d'abord
commencer par excusez le premier
ministre qui est à berlin en ce moment
même où il rencontre la chancelière
madame merkel et où il aura l'occasion
de renforcer encore l'amitié
franco-allemande et surtout de montrer à
ceux qui pourraient en douter qu'il ya
une très forte confiance en france dans
l'économie allemande en allemagne dans
l'économie française et je pense que
c'est utile que chacun pourra s'en
féliciter dans nos deux pays ont un rôle
important majeur partagé pour la
construction européenne étant il est
indispensable qu'ils avancent de concert
laissant de côté
je ne sais quels rumeurs manoeuvres
pensionnés et surtout mal venu mais je
veux en venir à votre question plus que
j'essaye de comprendre je vais d'abord
commencer par parce qu'elle n'était pas
si clair mais je vais essayer de le
démontrer je vais commencer par ce que
vous avez dit sur la tva pour clarifier
ce point c'est important
qu'avons nous fait en effet nous avons
estimé que la tva tels que
la précédente majorité avaient prévu de
l'augmenter était une ponction
insupportable sur le pouvoir d'achat des
français au moment où il y avait besoin
de soutenir l'activité
il s'agissait rappelons le d'augmenter
la tva le taux majoré de 1,6 point au
1er octobre 2012 est en effet
aujourd'hui si nicolas sarkozy avait été
réélu si cette majorité précédente avait
continué bien les français auraient eu
12 milliards d'euros en plus qui aurait
pesé sur leur pouvoir d'achat
nous l'avons supprimé nous avons eu
raison et nous faisons pas la même chose
nous ne faisons pas la même chose parce
que d'abord nous ne faisons pas au même
moment et par rapport au budget 2013 je
veux vous dire que c'est le 1er janvier
et je le dis ici devant les français le
1er janvier 2014 que les français
verront s'accroître une partie des taux
de tva parce que la deuxième chose que
nous on différemment de vous c'est que
d'abord nous sur deux fois moins deux
fois plus de compétitivité tes os x
moins de tva nous allons faire en sorte
aussi que ce soit modulé et notamment
que le taux réduit
lui qui concerne les produits de
première nécessité l'alimentation
l'énergie soit abaissée donc tout cela
étant dit de la manière la plus claire
je me tourne vers ce qu'ils vont voter
le budget 2013 pour le dire qu'il est
évidemment inchangée et que nous
prendrons les mesures utiles notamment
pour créer le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité l'emploi qui
s'appliquerait en 2013 et qui sera
financé en 2014 tout ça madame la
sénatrice est extrêmement clair
apparemment certains n'ont pas compris
je veux penser je veux penser que vous
aviez besoin d'explications et non pas
que vous étiez de mauvaise foi merci
monsieur françois zocchetto pour le
groupe de l'union des démocrates et
indépendants
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre du travail
ne croyez pas que nous interrogions
l'absence du premier ministre
en désavouant public publiquement jean
marc ayrault après ses déclarations
relatives aux 35 heures vous avez fait
la démonstration de votre autorité au
sein du gouvernement et vous avez pris
manifestement date pour la suite
six mois six mois c'est plus que la
période d'essai d'un salarié en
entreprise
qu'avez-vous fait six mois avec vous ses
240 mille chômeurs en plus six mois avec
vous c'est une litanie de plans sociaux
d'où psa candia aujourd'hui combien
d'autres combien d'autres
malheureusement demain dont je tairai
les noms dont je tairai par respect pour
les salariés
six mois c'est 20 milliards de
prélèvements obligatoires de plus sur
les entreprises et donc sur l'emploi de
demain
pensiez vous sincèrement qu après
l'interminable conférence de presse du
président de la république qui n'a
apporté aucune réponse claire
pensez vous que cela peut suffire à
masquer l'inaction du gouvernement où
elles cap ou conduisez-vous la france le
chômage et il diminue et il ne cesse
d'augmenter
plus de trois millions de chômeurs
aujourd'hui que faites vous vous
demander du temps vous jouer la montre
certes il ya les emplois d'avenir les
contrats de génération il est plus
facile de faire baisser le chômage en
recrutant des fonctionnaires qu'en
soutenant les efforts des entreprises
avez-vous diminuer la dépense publique
50 milliards de réduction vous nous
annoncez un jour 60 milliards le
lendemain où est la vérité
la vérité c'est que vous nous dites
jamais ce que vous allez faire si vous
voulez faire payer les riches
en réalité les millions de français ont
compris que vous aviez supprimer les
avantages liés aux heures
supplémentaires est liée à la
participation salariale
quels résultats la compétitivité de la
france et elle rétablit à la suite du
rapport gallo gallois vous annoncez 20
milliards 20 milliards de crédits
d'impôts aux entreprises caen en 2014
entre temps vous leur aurez pris 20
milliards d'impôts de plus en 2013
c'est avec ça que vous allez améliorer
la situation des entreprises
on a vraiment l'impression que le
gouvernement joue à la marelle avec
l'avenir de nos concitoyens cette
situation née
pas acceptable où est le redressement
dans la justice monsieur le ministre du
travail s'il vous plaît où en
serons-nous dans six mois même nos amis
allemands commencent à douter de la
france ils sont comme nos concitoyens
vous avez compris l'urgence sociale n'a
jamais été aussi lourd de monsieur le
ministre du travail lors de sa
conférence de presse le président de la
république je le cite a souhaité vouloir
faire nation qu'en pensez-vous faire
réforme
merci pour la réponse monsieur michel
sapin ministre du travail de l'emploi et
de la formation professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur zocchetto j'ai bien
fait de me méfier du compliment de
départ mais vous auriez aussi dû vous
méfier de la réalité des chiffres et de
la réalité des faits
car je suis tout prêt à parler des six
mois ou de l'année qui vont venir
c'est notre responsabilité pas la vôtre
la nôtre mais faites attention quand
vous parlez des six mois de l'année où
des cinq années qui ont précédé
parce que le premier chiffre que vous
devriez avoir en tête pour poser avec
modestie et modération des questions sur
le sujet extrêmement important de
l'emploi le premier chiffre que vous
devriez avoir en tête c'est le million
de chômeurs de plus en cinq ans dans la
majorité que vous avez soutenu ce qui
veut dire quoi
ce qui veut dire quoi c'est que ni ceux
qui ont dirigé hier ni ceux qui dirigent
aujourd'hui ne doit faire preuve de trop
de certitudes et d'arrogance et c'est
pour ça que nous sommes nous dans
l'action dans la décision
et même dans la mise en oeuvre des
décisions
je voudrais juste citer trois champs de
décision l'europe auquel a fait allusion
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances l'europe dont en ce moment même
le premier ministre s'occupe avec notre
partenaire fondamental et privilégié
qu'est l'allemagne
la remise en ordre et la réorientation
et la réorientation de l'europe
la sécurisation du système européen
la mise en oeuvre du programme de
croissance européen c'est l'emploi et
c'est pour l'emploi lorsque un pacte de
compétitivité est annoncée lorsqu'il est
dès maintenant pour toute une partie de
lui-même mise en oeuvre lorsqu il le
sera dès le début de l'année prochaine
pour la partie crédit d'impôt et dès
l'aller après pour son financement
c'est l'emploi lorsque vous mettons en
oeuvre les emplois d'avenir
le contrat de génération j'y reviendrai
c'est de l'emploi dont il s'agit et de
l'emploi le plus précieux monsieur le
sénateur celui des jeunes
car jamais et c'est la conséquence de la
toux du double échec de votre majorité
il n'y a eu autant de jeunes sans emploi
et sans formation
et ça c'est pas nos six mois c'est vous
disant vous disant de déchets de
difficulté est de mise au ban de la
société de la jeunesse de la france
c'est à elle que nous adressons
aujourd'hui vous avez échoué au cours
des cinq dernières années nous
réussirons pour les cinq prochaines
années merci la parole est à présent
monsieur alain richard pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés monsieur nuit
économie et des finances le gouvernement
a pris les décisions nécessaires pour
assurer la croissance durable de ce pays
en rétablissant sa compétitivité il nous
présente un budget destiné à mettre fin
à l'étouffement par la dette qui se
poursuivait depuis des années il a joué
aux côtés du président pour achever la
stabilisation du système financier
européen et notamment le système de
systèmes publics de supervision des
banques
nous sommes nombreux qui approuveront
cette stratégie dans sa cohérence
et comme le citoyen que nous
représentons nous sommes dans l'attenté
de ces résultats concrets une croissance
au rendez-vous des comptes extérieurs
équilibré de l'emploi et des ressources
supplémentaires
là dès 2013 représente à la fois des
potentialités et des risques les risques
tout le monde vous en parle et donc n'y
revient pas mais notre économie a ses
points forts
louis gallois les à relever et nous
avons de nombreux dans entre
entrepreneurs dans tous les secteurs
nous les rencontrons dans les
départements qui sont décidés à aller de
l'avant
il y à une croissance mondiale dans
laquelle nous prendrons notre part comme
les
européen qui réussissent nos partenaires
sociaux sont au travail pour trouver le
soubassement social de cet effort
collectif d'adaptation vous avez en main
quatre leviers pour franchir
positivement cette année de reconstituer
de remonter vers la croissance la
consommation des ménages
la qualité et l'innovation des
entreprises qu'il faut financer la
conquête de marchés extérieurs
le l'investissement publics et de
logement vous les utilisez tous avec des
marges de manoeuvre réduite et donc un
impératif majeur de cohérence et de
confiance
je vous remercie de nous résumer comment
voulais piloter cette phase de contre
attaque de notre économie pour nous
placer à la fin de cette année 2013
décisive dans la situation de reprise
solide qu'attendent les français
merci monsieur pierre moscovici ministre
de l'économie et des finances monsieur
le sénateur alain richard je voudrais
d'abord au moment où je vous parle moi
aussi après louis gallois a insisté sur
les points forts de notre économie et
sur ses atouts vous n'êtes pas sans le
savoir ce matin l'insee a annoncé les
chiffres pour la france
pour ce qui concerne le troisième
trimestre de l'année 2012 l'année en
cours peu d'économistes le pensais je
l'avais pour ma part prédit mais la
france au troisième trimestre après une
croissance positive de +0 2 point et
c'est dû notamment à la politique du
gouvernement qui a soutenu la croissance
intérieure et le pouvoir d'achat car
c'est là le moteur de cette croissance
pour ce trimestre et puis puisque mais
ne guettaient pas les mauvaises
nouvelles règles jouissez vous des
bonnes
mesdames et messieurs de l'opposition
soyez cohérents soyez dans l'unité
autour notre économie et puis ce matin
aussi la france a emprunté à des taux
d'intérêt historiquement bas ce qui est
un signe de confiance inédit majeure
dans notre économie est aussi je crois
de crédibilité de la politique que nous
menons alors vous m'interrogez sur la
cohérence
je veux vous dire que cette politique
nous allons la mener
sur trois points ou avec trois piliers
le premier vous le connaissez c'est le
sérieux budgétaire car il faut
désendetter le pays
le désendettement c'est l'endettement
c'est l'ennemi de l'économie
c'est l'ennemi des services publics tout
euros que nous gagnerons qui ne sera pas
consacré à la dette sera gagnée pour
l'éducation pour la justice pour
l'hôpital ou pour l'emploi nous mènerons
cette politique avec beaucoup de
résolutions
le deuxième pilier vous l'avez évoqué
c'est la construction européenne nous
travaillons à la réorienter je citerai
le pacte de croissance qui a été obtenue
de haute lutte
je citerai la taxe sur les transactions
financières ou encore la
recapitalisation de la banque européenne
d'investissement l'europe est en train
de sortir de son ornière
la zone euro est en train de sortir de
son ornière et l'action que le nom y est
pour quelque chose
enfin le troisième pilier c'est la
compétitivité que n'avait-on dit que
nous ne tiendrions pas compte du rapport
gallois qu'il allait être enterrée
il n'a pas été enterré il nous a
entraînés vers une politique sans
précédent
courageuse qui traite tous les facteurs
de la compétitivité la compétitivité
hors coûts et la compétitivité coût la
compétitivité prix et enfin comme pour
les trois mousquetaires et il ya quatre
piliers c'est la réforme du marché du
travail que mène michel sapin et qui est
un enjeu absolument historique
voilà ce que nous faisons je pense que
c'est une politique courageuse qui
tirera le pays de son ornière j'appelle
chacun à participer à la mobilisation et
au redressement est ainsi en effet nous
réussirons
madame eliane assassi pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen merci
monsieur le président monsieur nuit et
messieurs et mesdames et mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues hier françois hollande alors
candidat à tracer une perspective tracer
une voie il affirmé alors et avec juste
raison je le cite je vais vous dire ce
qu'est mon adversaire
cet adversaire c'est le monde de la
finance et conclut en déclarant si la
finance et l'adversaire il faut
l'affronter
il a donc c'est alors la nécessité d'un
pacte productif tournée vers l'emploi
puisant sa force dans la mise au pas de
la finance
six mois après l'élection de françois
hollande qui je le rappelle n'aurait pu
s'effectuer sans les 11% des front de
gauche nous constatons que
l'affrontement avec le monde de la
finance de l'actionnariat des agences de
notation n'est plus à l'ordre du jour la
sphère des pigeons et quand même un
symbole les vieux mots ce que l'on a 6
ans beau si souvent entendu ces
dernières années sont de retour
coût du travail compétitivité réduction
des dépenses la compétitivité c'est un
concept qui a été inventé pour justifié
l'austérité la soumission des salariés à
la logique patronale accepter cette voie
c'est n'ont plus affronté la finance
c'est s'y soumettre jamais n'est mis en
rapport la notion de compétitivité et
celle de la rentabilité financière
jamais ni mis en rapport le coût pour la
société toute entière du chômage de la
précarité du manque de soins
savez vous par exemple que les accidents
du travail coûte 13 milliards d'euros à
la société plus que la réduction des
dépenses publiques que vous voulez
imposer
chaque année à notre pays allez-vous par
exemple interpellé le patronat sur ce
point les sénateurs de mon groupe les
parlementaires communistes avec le front
de gauche même si cela semble déplaire
affiche une cohérence par leurs bottes
sur les lois de finances l'an dernier la
gauche et nathalie sénatoriale avait
trouvé une autre voie une alternative
budgétaire encore imparfaite certes mais
réelle
aujourd'hui nous proposons des
amendements pratiquement aucun n'a été à
ce jour retenu comme un camouflet
infligé à la majorité de gauche au sénat
pourtant un seul d'entre eux un seul
taxant la spéculation sur le rachat des
leurs achats des entreprises en
difficulté rapporterait 10 7 milliards
d'euros
monsieur le ministre ni vous ni nous ne
souhaitons le retour de la droite au
règne de notre pays
mais allez vous enfin avec le
gouvernement étudiait sérieusement nos
propositions qui loi de re veulent
relever de la surenchère sont celles de
la cohérence et du respect des
engagements pris
merci monsieur pierre moscovici ministre
l'économie et des finances madame la
sénatrice eliane assassi croyais que je
respecte
comme le gouvernement les convictions
qui sont les vôtres la cohérence qui est
la vôtre ce que la force politique que
vous représentez peux t'exprimer en même
temps je veux dire que je ne partage pas
cette vision des choses et je crois que
vous faites fausse route en soulignant
un espèce de procès en ranimant qui
n'est pas conforme à la vérité nous ne
changerons pas de cap
nous avons tracé un cap et c'est ce cap
là que nous allons suivre
madame la sénatrice et je veux revenir
sur quelques uns des arguments que vous
avez évoquées pour montrer à quel point
vous vous trompez et à quel point le
président de la république et au
contraire il l'a montré dans sa
conférence de presse dans la continuité
des engagements qu'il a pris devant le
pays et que votre parti vos parties ont
accepté vous parler d'un pacte productif
mais c'est bien de ça dont il s'agit
dans quelques semaines je reviendrai
devant vous pour présenter ici le projet
de bande publics pour l'investissement
première
position du candidat françois hollande
qui sera la banque des pme la banque des
yeux pays la banque de l'innovation la
banque des territoires est ce que ce
n'est pas un élément du pacte productif
et vous critiquez le mot compétitivité
je crois que vous faites radicalement
fausses routes
nous sommes dans une compétition nous
livrons une bataille c'est une bataille
économique cette bataille et les
mondiale il faut muscler l'appareil
productif français qui peut dire le
contraire qui peut se réjouir de la
désindustrialisation qui en réalité vous
le savez touche d'abord les plus
défavorisés les cools ouvrière les
classes ouvrières
nous avons besoin de relancer l'appareil
productif de la même façon nous allons
poursuivre notre combat pour la justice
j'évoquais il y à une seconde les
chiffres de la croissance pour le
troisième trimestre 2012
et si cela se passe comme ça c'est parce
que nous avons agi pour le pouvoir
d'achat
c'est parce que nous avons augmenté
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire c'est
parce que nous avons fait diminuer les
prix du carburant c'est parce que nous
avons donné un coup de pouce au smic
c'est parce que nous avons étalé la
facture nous héritions sur le gaz en
faveur des couches populaires
c'est cela que nous avons fait et plutôt
plutôt que de vous livrer à ce procès
que je crois malvenu je vous invite à
nous rejoindre dans ce combat qui est le
combat pour la justice qui est le combat
pour le redressement qui est un combat
aussi qui mène à des réformes qui sont
dialoguer concertée c'est un changement
de méthode c'est un changement de cap
en effet ce pays a maintenant un cap
il a un capitaine tout cela se fonde sur
un diagnostic qu'ils y allaient aussi
juste rejoignez-nous madame dans un
combat commun qui doit être celui de la
gauche
merci madame hellénique est pour le
groupe écologiste
ma question s'adresse à madame la garde
des sceaux monsieur le président mes
chers collègues
quelques jours après que monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur a déclaré qu'il
collaborerait avec l'espagne en matière
de lutte contre le terrorisme
or martin a été arrêté par hasard
les écologistes eux prennent donc acte
que fortuna déesse de la chance est avec
lui au-delà de cette militante d'un
parti batasuna autorisé de ce côté ci
des pyrénées est interdit de l'autre se
pose la question de l'espace judiciaire
européen et du mécanisme du mandat
d'arrêt européen intégré au droit
français
le 9 mars 2004 la validité du mandat
d'arrêt européen exige que les faits
reprochés dans l'état émetteurs face
encourir plus de trois ans
d'emprisonnement mais n'inclut aucune
obligation d'avoir une double
incrimination dans le pays d'accueil et
dans le pays émetteurs or il n'existe
pas de référentiel européen de l'échelle
des peines ni de la qualification des
délits et des peines
à quand une réflexion sur ce sujet je
sais que les députés européens vers et à
lots ont interpellé en urgence la
commission européenne dans le cadre de
rohr martin le dossier présenté par la
justice espagnole a semblé solide temps
à la cour d'appel de pau qu'à la cour de
cassation est qu'à la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme la dissolution de
batasuna espagnol a été validé par un
juge reconnu pour son intégrité en
matière de lutte contre les dictatures
le juge garzon est confirmée là aussi
par la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme la justice espagnole est saisie
nous ne sommes plus au temps de franco
et nous pouvons espérer qu'elle sera
sereine
cependant
en juillet 2011 à l'occasion de la
précédente arrestation d'aurore martin
le futur président de la république
déclarait qu'il y avait un principe de
clémence à faire respecter
de plus la résolution du conflit basque
est en cours depuis la conférence de
conciliation daté du 17 octobre 2011 et
le taa renoncer à la lutte armée
c'est pourquoi les français françaises
peuvent légitimement s'interroger sur
l'absence de possibilité de retarder une
remise à un état tiers d'une citoyenne
française décision particulièrement
grave
le mal est fait reste une question
comment la france entend tel assurer la
protection consulaire d'or martin qui
n'a toujours pas reçu la visite du
consul de france
merci monsieur alain vidalis ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement
merci merci monsieur le président madame
la sénatrice je vous demande de bien
vouloir excuser le garde des sceaux
qu'elle est en déplacement qu'elle n'a
pas pu nous rejoindre à temps utile la
française aurore martin militante de
batasuna a été arrêté le 1er novembre
2012 dans les pyrénées atlantiques puis
remise aux autorités espagnoles en
application du mandat d'arrêt européen
dont elle faisait l'objet depuis 2010
les autorités espagnoles lui reproche
d'avoir participé en espagne à des
réunions publiques comme membre de
batasuna considéré comme le bras
politique de l'organisation séparatiste
basque eta est interdite de l'autre côté
des pyrénées
aurore martin a comparu le 2 novembre au
matin devant un juge de l'audience
nationale de madrid
elle a été placée sous mandat de dépôt
le ministre de la justice a rappelé que
la remise de madame martin à la justice
espagnole s'est opérée dans le strict
cadre du mandat d'arrêt européen
les caractéristiques du mandat d'arrêt
européen sont les suivantes
il permet la remise de nationaux il
s'opère de juge en juge sans
intervention des autorités
gouvernementales
le mandat d'arrêt européen est ainsi une
procédure uniquement conduite par les
autorités judiciaires
r c'est l'autorité judiciaire en
l'espèce le juge d'instruction espagnol
qui aimait le mandat c'est l'autorité
judiciaire seule qui en contrôle la
régularité soit en l'espèce le parquet
général et la chambre d'instruction de
pau puis la cour de cassation puis la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme je
précise que le parquet général de pau
s'agissant de l'exécution était lié pour
l'exécution de ce mandat par les défis
de la décision définitive de la chambre
de l'instruction
en l'espèce toutes les voies de recours
d'aurore martin ont été rejetées par
arrêt du 15 décembre 2010 la cour de
cassation a rejeté son pourvoi
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a aussi déclaré irrecevable une demande
présentée par la jeune femme
en mai dernier le mandat d'arrêt
européen est enfin utiliser sans que
soit imposé la condition de la double
incrimination pour une liste précise
d'infractions graves
punis d'au moins trois mois trois ans en
particulier le terrorisme
cette caractéristique rend dès lors sans
objet pour ces infractions
une harmonisation des délits et des
peines le gouvernement et la garde des
sceaux sont bien entendu très attentif à
la situation de l'art nationaux aurore
martin bénéficie de manière très
concrète de la protection consulaire
accordés par la france à tous et
nationaux et en particulier à ceux qui
sentent en détention
la france est également très attentive à
la suite de la procédure désormais
conduite en espagne par des autorités
judiciaires dont elle respecte
scrupuleusement l'indépendance assuré
dans le cadre démocratique espagnole
merci monsieur yvan kohler pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie
madame la ministre l'indépendance
énergétique de la france se doit
constituer une priorité
sur cette question le groupe rdse
partage l'analyse de l'excellent rapport
gallois remis la semaine dernière à
monsieur le premier ministre à savoir je
cite il faut préserver le faible coût de
l'énergie car c'est un réel atout pour
notre industrie et sa compétitivité
cela passe par des économies d'énergie
bien sûr mais aussi par le développement
des énergies renouvelables par le
maintien d'une filière nucléaire
d'excellence
cela passe également par la proposition
numéro 5 de louis gallois proposition
qui est la suivante je cite à nouveau
il faut poursuivre les recherches sur
les techniques d'exploitation des gaz de
schiste car si notre pays dispose des
réserves annoncées
il serait irresponsable selon nous de
s'en priver c'est aussi du reste la
position affirmée il ya deux jours par
le président de la république puisqu'il
a précisé concernant les gaz de schiste
que la recherche devait continuer pour
trouver d'autres techniques que la
facturation hydraulique beaucoup trop
polluantes
nous partageons cette position comme le
président de la république
le groupe rdse est opposée à la
technique de la fracturation hydraulique
et comme le président de la république
nous exprimons que cette opposition ne
signifie pas que l'on renonce à
l'exploitation future des gaz de schiste
c'est la position que nous avions
exprimé ici même en juin 2011 lors de
l'examen de la proposition de loi sur
cette question non l'obscurantisme ne
doit pas prendre le pas sur le principe
de précaution
or madame la ministre quelle est la
position du gouvernement puisque celui
ci n'a pas retenu la proposition numéro
cinq du rapport gallois lors de la
présentation par le premier ministre du
pacs du pacte national pour la
croissance et la compétitivité emploi
il est vrai me direz vous que c'est
avant que le président de la république
le style vous plaît merci madame la
ministre sur les gaz de schiste la
recherche est un impératif majeur de
notre politique énergétique recherche
pour évaluer précisément l'état de nos
réserves et recherche bien évidemment
sur les techniques d'exploitation aussi
comment le gouvernement entend tir
encourager et appuyer cette recherche et
notamment les organismes tout son relief
paix le cnrs brgm et ifremer
quels moyens l'état va-t-il consacré à
cette recherche en fait madame la
ministre
ne croyez-vous pas que l'intérêt général
et l'indépendance énergétique de la
france doivent passer avant le respect
d'accords électoraux
alors merci madame delphine batho
ministre de l'écologie du développement
durable et de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur yvon collin
je voulais vous rappeler d'ailleurs en
ce qui concerne bon la politique de
l'énergie qu'elle va donner lieu un
grand débat national sur la politique de
transition énergétique
chaque peuple est souverain dans ses
choix énergétiques et la france vous
l'avez rappelé a interdit par une loi de
juillet 2011 sous la précédente
législature la fracturation hydraulique
elle a interdit la représentation
nationale parce que cette technique de
la fracturation hydraulique comporte des
risques d'atteinte irréversibles à
l'environnement et des risques pour la
santé humaine que je voulais rappeler
des risques pour la consommation de la
ressource en eau des émanations de
méthane
la pollution de nappes phréatiques avec
des additifs chimiques des pros pack
temps et des adjuvants la remontée
de métaux lourds dont l'arsenic qui sont
contenus dans les profondeurs le risque
de micro séismes et de séismes comme
cela s'est produit en grande bretagne et
enfin des risques pour nos paysages
puisqu'il s'agit de vastes étendues qui
seraient utilisés pour l'extraction
voilà la situation qui a conduit le
peuple français au travers de serre en
présentant à prendre cette décision et
le président de la république lors de la
conférence environnementale a confirmé
cette décision et a aussi demandé au
gouvernement de prononcer le rejet des
demandes de permis de recherches qui
étaient en cours notamment celui de
cahors celui de beaumont de lomagne
aucune loi n'interdit la recherche
scientifique monsieur le sénateur mais
s'il s'agit en évoquant la recherche de
dire qu'il faudrait permettre la
fracturation hydraulique à des fins de
recherche ce n'est pas la position du
gouvernement donc je le dis bien
clairement aucune loi n'interdit la
recherche mais s'il s'agit au travers de
la recherche d'autoriser la fracturation
hydraulique
il ne peut pas en être question la loi
de 2011 sur ce point là était ambiguë
pour finir je vous dirai un mot de ce
que vous avez dit sur l'obscurantisme
moi je suis pour le progrès le
gouvernement et pour le progrès il est
pour la science et le progrès ce n'est
pas la croissance salle ce n'est pas le
recours à des techniques qui dégradent
l'environnement le progrès c'est la
croissance verte le progrès ce sont les
énergies du futur ce sont les énergies
marines ce sont les énergies
renouvelables sur lesquelles la france
un potentiel industriel considérable
créateur d'emploi créateurs de richesses
et qui peut nous permettre de répondre à
la question que vous avez posé sur notre
indépendance énergétique
sinon mon père me dit je sais qui
la parole est à monsieur albéric de
montgolfier pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
cette plus sérieux vous avez ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances elle porte
sur les difficultés de financement des
collectivités et sur leurs conséquences
sur l'économie
ce que monsieur le ministre de
nombreuses communes mais également des
intercommunalités des départements
rencontrent des difficultés d'accès au
crédit et n'arrive pas emprunter à des
taux élevés et les causes elles sont
connues c'est la disparition de dexia
c'est l'application par anticipation des
ratios de bâle iii que les états unis
ont d'ailleurs décidé unilatéralement
d'appeler de reporter signer dié mais
c'est également le fait que les banques
se voient priver d'une ressource à
travers l'augmentation du livret a
donc voilà les cause de cette difficulté
d'accès au crédit
et aujourd'hui les solutions dégagées ne
permettent que de répondre très
partiellement à ces difficultés
malgré l'ouverture de crédits la caisse
des dépôts
malgré l'intervention de la banque
postale il manque plusieurs milliards
pour financer nos hôpitaux aux finances
et nos collectivités
et lorsque les collectivités restent
empreintes et c'est toujours pour des
durées trop courte
dans ces conditions comment financer des
investissements lourds
comment financer des routes comment de
financer des réseaux d'eau comment
financer des réseaux d'assainissement
le gouvernement nous a récemment annoncé
qu'il relevait le taux du livret a et il
va ainsi dégagé une collecte
supplémentaire
ma question est pourquoi ne pas utiliser
c'était par une réglementée pourquoi ne
pas utiliser cette collecte
supplémentaire pour recréer un
financement de long terme des
collectivités à des taux bas
comme c'est le cas pour le logement
social et plus généralement est ce que
le gouvernement a des solutions à nous
proposer pour financer sur la durée les
collectivités je crois qu'il y va de la
survie de très nombreuses entreprises du
bâtiment et des travaux publics qui
dépendent de la commande publique
merci
merci pour vous répondre madame anne
marie escoffier ministre chargé de la
décentralisation
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur la question que vous avez posé
est au coeur des préoccupations du
gouvernement vous savez que depuis des
mois et des mois nous sommes en train de
suivre la situation des collectivités
locales qui ont de plus en plus vous
l'avez dit de difficultés pour accéder
aux différents crédits
le gouvernement n'a pas attendu pour
essayer de mettre en oeuvre des
dispositions qui concourent tout à la
mise à disposition des collectivités de
moyens de financement qui répondraient
vous le savez très bien plus que moi au
moins aussi bien que moi que aujourd'hui
nos collectivités locales participent à
plus de 71 % à l'investissement public
d'où la nécessité de subvenir bien
entendu à leurs difficultés dans ce
cadre là il ne leur viendrait pas
longuement sur la banque postale la
banque postale qui de par les mesures
qu'elles viennent prendre avait déjà
dégagé un milliard de crédits qui vient
qui va ont dégagé un milliard encore sur
2013 mais surtout parce que ça répond à
un vrai besoin de nos petites
collectivités locales qui va permettre d
accès à des crédits inférieurs à 200
mille euros qui jusqu'ici était le
montant qui était relevé
là dès maintenant dès la semaine
dernière les demandes de crédit à
hauteur de cent mille euros ont pu
trouver des solutions et ce taux
pourrait même être baisser ce seuil
pourrait être baissée à partir de 2013
je voudrais maintenant revenir à la
caisse des dépôts et consignations que
vous évoquiez s'agissant de la caisse
des dépôts et consignations l'année 2012
a permis d'ouvrir 5 milliards de crédits
2 milliards dès le mois de mai trois
milliards dès le mois de juillet et je
veux le ajouté quand même et le dire le
taux d'emprunt de la caisse a été baissé
et sensiblement baissé à la demande du
gouvernement
il va de soi que aujourd'hui on le sait
bien les besoins des collectivités vous
l'avez dit des collectivités des
hôpitaux est un besoin essentiel et la
question se pose de savoir si le
doublement du livret
ne peut pas y concourir il va de soi il
va de soi que aujourd'hui le
gouvernement travaille sur cette
hypothèse est sûre sur cette
problématique là vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la caisse des dépôts et
consignations mobilise des fonds d'
épargne sur deux modes de financement
d'une part l'affectation dans veloppe de
crédit à moyen terme pour des
investissements non fléchés et à long
terme pour des investissements
thématiques
c'est de cette enveloppe là sur cette
enveloppe là qu'il faut travailler et
c'est sur cette enveloppe là que
justement le doublement de la le
doublement du plafond du livret a
permettra de trouver des solutions sien
ce à quoi en tout état de cause le
gouvernement travaille pour la prochaine
échéance puisque à la fin de cette année
la dernière enveloppe pluriannuel aura
été utilisée je peux vous assurer de la
volonté de la détermination très forte
du gouvernement de trouver des solutions
pour répondre à l'eau à la nécessité
pour les collectivités territoriales de
trouver des crédits pour répondre alors
alors aux investissements qu'elles ont
auxquels elles ont à faire face et qui
reste une priorité pour l'emploi et la
croissance
merci monsieur claude berri demain pour
le groupe socialiste apparentés
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre du
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle
monsieur le ministre la situation de
l'emploi ne cesse de se dégrader
et ce n'est pas nouveau monsieur
zocchetto tout le monde le sait qu'entre
2007 et 2012
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
augmenté de plus d'un million de
personnes et nous avons perdu 700 mille
emplois industriels en disant ne restons
pas simplement sur six mois aujourd'hui
la france et les français font encore
les frais de la politique du précédent
gouvernement
les plantations se multiplient le rythme
des destructions d'emplois s'accélèrent
au troisième trimestre 2012
l'emploi salarié a encore reculé de plus
de 50 mille postes
globalement selon l'insee après dix sept
mois de hausse continue
le taux de chômage devrait atteindre
10,2 pour cent à la fin de 2012 et pôle
emploi compte plus de 3,3 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi durant toute la
campagne
et dès son entrée en fonction le
président de la république a tenu sur
l'état de la france
un langage de vérité et de
responsabilité
lors de sa conférence de presse mardi
face à la hausse du chômage qui devrait
continuer encore pendant un an il a pris
des engagements ambitieux et il a
réaffirmé l'objectif d' inverser la
tendance
difficile ici fin 2013 il s'agit là d'un
signal très fort
le gouvernement a déjà agi avec les
emplois d'avenir qui doivent offrir dès
2013 une expérience professionnelle à
plus de cent mille jeunes ils se
mobilisent notamment à travers le
rendez-vous historique majeur que
constitue la négociation sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi
il se mobilisera encore avec la création
des contrats de génération
monsieur le ministre chacun sent bien
que votre action et celle du
gouvernement en matière d'emploi doit
être d'autant plus ambitieuse que la
tâche à accomplir est difficile dans ces
conditions ma question est simple
pouvez vous nous indiquer où nous en
sommes par rapport à la mise en place d
emplois d'avenir aux négociations pour
la sécurisation de l'emploi à
l'avancement des futurs contrats de
génération
je vous remercie de votre réponse
merci monsieur michel sapin ministre du
travail et de l'emploi
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur nous serons tous
d'accord ici pour souligner la gravité
de la situation de l'emploi et donc à
partir de là la nécessité de prendre des
décisions le plus rapidement possible
qui est une efficacité la plus forte
possible
je ne reviens pas sur les aspects
économiques européens financier
budgétaire du rééquilibrage redonner
confiance
redonner un avenir redonner des
perspectives refaire démarrer la
croissance de notre économie et le
ministre de l'économie et des finance
soulignait la croissance de ce troisième
trimestre alors qu'on s'attendait au
contraire à une situation stable
il y a des éléments qui nous permettent
de penser que cette croissance sera
porteuse d'emplois mais cela ne suffit
pas dans une situation aussi dégradée
que celle d'aujourd'hui
il faut aussi des outils des outils au
service de l'emploi d'abord au service
de l'emploi des jeunes
vous avez cité ces emplois d'avenir il
se met dès aujourd'hui en place sur
l'ensemble du territoire
nous sommes nombreux ministres je suis
persuadé que vous êtes nombreux
parlementaires à participer jour après
jour à la signature d'un certain nombre
d'emplois d'avenir et quand je vois le
regard de ces jeunes lorsqu'ils sont là
qu'ils viennent signer ce qui est
souvent leur premier contrat durable
je me dis que nous faisons oeuvre utile
non pas seulement pour eux mais pour la
société toute entière
vous avez parlé du contrat de génération
le contrat de génération c'était une
idée du candidat
c'est une décision dans son principe du
président et c'est le fruit d'une
négociation entre les partenaires
sociaux
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs et
certains ici ils seront plus sensibles
que d'autres monsieur le président
larcher
la négociation entre partenaires sociaux
ça n'est pas une manière de retarder la
décision ça n'est pas une manière de
reporter sur d'autres la responsabilité
c'est une manière de préparer la
décision est la décision durable
acceptée par
et mises en oeuvre rapidement le contrat
de génération ce seront des jeunes à qui
seront offerts des emplois nouveaux
ce seront des plus âgés dans
l'entreprise qui ne seront pas poussés
en dehors de l'entreprise et ce sacre de
transfert de compétences entre le jeune
et le plus âgé
cette ce contrat de génération a fait
l'objet d'une négociation tous les
partenaires tous
du côté patronal comme du sable côté
syndical ont signé le 12 décembre
prochain
le projet de loi sera adopté en conseil
des ministres et vous aurez à vous
prononcer sur ce projet de loi
sur l'ensemble de ces bancs dès le début
de l'année prochaine
enfin monsieur le président je crois que
j'ai été un peu perturbée par le
déclenchement de votre chronomètre
tardif
enfin sept grandes négociations sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi
elle est décisive absolument décisive je
veux dire simplement les partenaires
sociaux ont entre les mains
aujourd'hui les moyens de mettre en
oeuvre une vraie et bonne réforme du
marché du travail au sens le plus
profond du terme plus de sécurité pour
celui qui est dans l'emploi et plus de
capacité d'adaptation pour la
collectivité représente entreprises
c'est ça l'avenir aussi de notre
compétitivité
merci monsieur le ministre nous avions
rattraper le retard
la parole est à présent à madame
laurence rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable des
énergies vous avait annoncé la semaine
dernière que débutera la semaine
prochaine le grand débat sur la
transition énergétique
ce débat qui figurait parmi les
engagements du président de la
république est très attendu il est
attendu par les ong est attendu par les
acteurs économiques du monde de
l'énergie celle des énergies
traditionnelles comme celle des énergies
renouvelables comme aussi ceux d énergie
des industries électro-intensives il est
attendu par les professionnels du
bâtiment et de l'efficacité thermique
enfin il est attendu par les
parlementaires dont je suis qui juge que
nous devons tout à la fois engagé vite
et fort
la réduction de notre consommation
d'énergie fossile afin de diviser par
quatre d'ici 2050 nos émissions de co2
et je précise à nos collègues à cet
instant
que les gaz et huiles de schiste
appartiennent bien à la catégorie des
énergies fossiles émettrices de co2 et
en même temps de ramener de 75 à 50%
notre la part du nucléaire dans notre
mix électrique
il est attendu aussi car la transition
énergétique n'est pas un handicap mais
une opportunité pour l'économie
française et sa compétitivité
or l'indolence du gouvernement précédent
à fragiliser le secteur des énergies
renouvelables et a fait prendre à la
france un retard considérable dans leur
développement
les enjeux de son débat sont associés le
plus grand nombre de citoyens à la
définition de ce mix énergétique de
rendre acceptable la diversification est
aussi de leur montrer le chemin de
l'efficacité la sobriété énergétique
madame la ministre pourriez-vous nous
décrire et nous préciser la manière dont
ce débat va être organisé comment il va
être déployée sur le territoire pour
associer le plus grand nombre de
citoyens et l'acteur la place que vous
entendez réservé à la représentation
parlementaire et enfin le calendrier que
vous nous proposez c'est madame delphine
batho ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice laurence rossignol le grand
débat sur la transition énergétique doit
d'abord être un débat citoyen un débat
populaire dans lequel chaque français va
pouvoir donner son avis sur les grands
choix que va devoir faire la nation en
matière d'énergie qui sont des choix
stratégiques pour notre économie pour
notre industrie pour nos objectifs
environnementaux qui sont aussi
stratégique obtient point de vue social
parce que beaucoup de français sont
inquiets de l'augmentation de leur
facture énergétique et dans ce débat-là
dans cette ambition qu elle celle de la
transition énergétique la france dispose
d'atouts et dispose d'un potentiel
considérable d'abord nous sommes un pays
qui considèrent que l'énergie est un
bien public
ensuite nous avons des grands acteurs
mondiaux de la production et de la
fourniture d'énergie nous avons des
filières d'excellence nous avons un
potentiel dans les énergies
renouvelables nous avons l'engagement
des salariés des grandes entreprises
publiques de l'énergie et nous avons une
ambition environnementale est en effet
ce débat doit nous permettre d'atteindre
l'objectif fixé par le président de la
république à l'horizon 2020
5 et le facteur 4 en 2050 ce sera
l'objet de la loi de programmation pour
la transition énergétique qui résultera
des recommandations du débat et sur
lequel sur laquelle le parlement se
prononcera ce débat national est ouvert
à tous chacun pourra y apporter ses
idées sans exclusive sans tabou il y à
un comité de pilotage qui est composé de
personnalités reconnues qui doit être
garant de la pluralité des points vu des
avis qui sera le garant des règles du
débat aura vocation à promouvoir ce
débat à l'animé il y à il y aura un
parlement du débat qui sera basée sur la
gouvernance à 5 + 1
c'est l'expression qui a été retenue par
la conférence environnementale mais il
s'agit des corps intermédiaires c'est à
dire les représentants des syndicats des
entreprises des ong environnementales
des élus locaux des consommateurs et des
parlementaires puisque c'est le
complément qui a été apporté par rapport
à ce qui était la gouvernance du
grenelle de l'environnement la mise en
place de ce parlement du débat
interviendra très rapidement elle est
décalée de quelques jours à la demande
de l'association des maires de france en
raison de l'intervention du président de
la république mardi prochain il y aura
un comité d experts pluraliste là aussi
qui établira les scénarios qui seront
mis en débat les entreprises seront
évidemment associée aux organisations et
seront régulièrement consultés et
surtout il y aura un comité de liaison
avec les associations d'élus jeu pour
organiser les débats décentralisés qui
commenceront à partir du mois de février
prochain
c'est à dire qu'entre maintenant et le
mois de février vont être produits tous
les éléments et les scénarios qui seront
mis en débat qui seront discutés
notamment dans des conférences
régionales de l'énergie actuellement
nous discutons avec les ong avec les
syndicats avec les représentants des
entreprises et les associations d'élus
de la charte du débat qui fixera les
règles d'engagement
j'entends j'entends des ricanements
mais permettez moi
permettez moi permettez moi de finir sur
cela d'abord le sénat sera associé et
siègera et participera à l'ensemble de
ce processus et ensuite nous sommes sur
des enjeux considérables
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs qui
engage la nation pas simplement pour ce
quinquennat mais pour des décennies et
la méthode qu'assume le gouvernement
quand on doit engager la nation pour des
décennies
c'est celle du débat démocratique avec
tous les acteurs concernés et cette
méthode nous l'assumons nous la
revendiquons
merci la parole est enfin monsieur bruno
jean pour le groove le groupe union pour
un mouvement populaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
vendredi dernier 9 novembre le gérant
d'un point presse au 6 avenue des
chutes-lavie dans le 4e arrondissement
de marseille a été tué lors d'un
braquage
monsieur mohamed chig eni est mort de
plusieurs coups de couteau à la poitrine
pour quelques dizaines d'euros
cet homme de 50 ans ancien professeur de
philosophie était un honorable
commerçants qui laisse derrière lui une
femme et deux enfants en quelques mois
monsieur le ministre il s'agit du
deuxième meurtre commis dans l'un de mes
arrondissement lors d'un règlement de
compte il ya un peu plus d'un mois
un individu avait été tué par balles à
la terrasse d'un café au milieu de
nombreux clients pour trouver des
événements aussi tragiques dans les
arrondissements dont je suis maire
depuis dix sept ans il faut remonter à
l'année 1994
la victime était alors le brigadier de
police
claudie darcis âgé de 36 ans tué un
service d'une balle en pleine poitrine
le 24 février 94
à cet instant je tiens à saluer le
travail remarquable des policiers
marseillais sur le terrain et
l'implication personnelle
importante du nouveau préfet de police
après les promesses du premier ministre
et du ministre de l'intérieur
d'augmenter les effectifs de police à
marseille et les annonces successives de
renfort de 300 puis de 205
fonctionnaires et suite à l'arrivée
récente de 135 d'entre eux je
souhaiterais monsieur le ministre
savoir quel est le nombre exact
envisager la mort de ce commerçant
prouve que la délinquance gagne des
quartiers calmes
d'ordinaire les hommes de sécurité
renforcées sud et nord ainsi que la
vidéosurveillance du centre ville mis en
place par la municipalité de jean claude
gaudin provoque un déplacement immédiat
de la délinquance
monsieur le ministre je souhaiterais
savoir s'il est prévu que les renforts
attendus sont majoritairement sur le
terrain et quelle sera la proportion
d'entre eux dans les arrondissements
dont je suis maire les 4e et 5e
arrondissements qui sont devenus vous
l'avez compris la cible des délinquants
et enfin vous comprendrez aussi mon
souci que dans le cadre du plan anti
hold up diplôme dalton ces
arrondissements ne soit pas aussi les
oublier merci monsieur manuel valls
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur bruno gilles
je tient évidemment à mon tour à
exprimer mon émotion est dressé toutes
mes condoléances
une nouvelle fois à la famille de
mohamed chelli ni à ses proches et je
comprends l'émoi que cet acte suscite
parmi les marseillais les habitants de
ce quartier ses voisins les commerçants
de proximité à marseille ou ailleurs
ceci doit pouvoir accomplir leur travail
utile à notre société en toute sécurité
une enquête judiciaire est en cours je
ne doute pas que les agents de la police
judiciaire parviendront à identifier et
arrêter les auteurs de ce crime
depuis le début du quinquennat
début de la législature marseille est au
coeur et au centre de nos attentions
mais nous savons en même temps qu'il
faudra du temps pour faire face pour
répondre aux défis de la délinquance
d'autant plus que les marseillais se
sont aguerris fatigués des effets
d'annoncés
le premier ministre apporter une réponse
globale lors du comité interministériel
du 6 septembre puis lors de son
déplacement à marseille et pas
uniquement sur les questions de sécurité
c'est la première fois qu'un
gouvernement fait de marseille deuxième
ville de notre pays une priorité pour sa
sécurité mais aussi pour son
développement économique
depuis le 2 novembre cent vingt 120
fonctionnaires de police supplémentaires
sont arrivés en renfort
quarante gendarmes étaient déjà sur
place
après l'été ils permettront que la
présence policière sur la voie publique
soit renforcé et notamment au travers
des deux zones de sécurité prioritaires
annoncées cet été pour les quartiers
nord hier ce matin pour les quartiers
sud et vous avez raison c'est tout
marseille qui doit être concerné ça veut
bien dire qu'il y avait un lourd
problème de délinquance et d'insécurité
sur cette ville trente fonctionnaires
affectés à la police judiciaire et 15
hausse dis-je arriveront dans les
prochaines semaines car il faut
s'attaquer à l'économie souterraine au
trafic de drogue au trafic d'armes qui
gangrène les quartiers de cette ville et
occuper tout l'espace public quartiers
nord quartier sud centre ville ça reste
une priorité mais évidemment suite aux
effets logique que vous décriviez c'est
toute la ville qui doit être sécurisé je
me réjouie qu'enfin la ville de
marseille est mise progressivement en
place un plan de vidéoprotection et
s'est doté progressivement d'une police
municipale à la hauteur des enjeux
et puis avec sylvia pinel évidemment
nous sommes préoccupés de la situation
des buralistes
nous recevrons bientôt le président de
l'association des buralistes
france pour la mise en place de ce plan
hold up qui doit concerner tous les
buralistes de france parce qu'avec les
stations service avec des bureaux de
poste pour des raisons liées aussi à la
présence de l'argent ces commerces sont
vulnérables
voilà monsieur le sénateur la lutte
contre l'insécurité la délinquance est
une cause nationale et je me réjouis que
tous les élus aujourd'hui aille dans le
même sens
ce qui veut dire que chacun est
convaincu que le gouvernement et
crédibles sur cette question comme sur
toutes les autres merci mes chers
collègues je vais vous donner lecture de
l'ordre du jour du lundi 19 novembre
2012 à 14h30 proposition de résolution
européenne relative
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct du sénat on se
retrouve dans quelques instants avec
nous inviter pour refaire ensemble la
séance
on refait la séance après les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement sur public
sénat avec dans quelques instants nos
invités pour venir débattre des
questions d'actualité cet après midi au
sénat les gaz de schiste le pacte de
compétitivité ou encore et bien ce qui
s'est passé en corse un énième
assassinat hier nous allons y revenir
dans quelques instants avec nos invités
qui vont nous rejoindre dans cette salle
de conférences du sénat
mais je vous propose tout de suite de
réentendre un premier extrait de ces
questions d'actualité aujourd'hui
il s'agit de michel sapin qui répondait
à une question sur la croissance et sur
les chiffres du chômage et il prend à
partie et les rangs de la droite
écouter lorsque à pacte de compétitivité
est annoncée lorsqu'il est dès
maintenant pour toute une partie de
lui-même mise en oeuvre lorsqu il le
sera dès le début de l'année prochaine
pour la partie crédit d'impôt et dès
l'aller après pour son financement
c'est l'emploi lorsque vous mettons en
oeuvre les emplois d'avenir
le contrat de génération j'y reviendrai
c'est de l'emploi dont il s'agit et de
l'emploi le plus précieux
monsieur le sénateur celui des jeunes
car jamais et c'est la conséquence de la
toux du double échec de votre majorité
il n'y a eu autant de jeunes sans emploi
et sans formation
et ça c'est pas nos six mois si vous
disant vos dix ans de d'échec de
difficulté est de mise au ban de la
société de la jeunesse de la france
c'est à elle que nous adressons
aujourd'hui vous avez échoué au kode5